[Musique]
demain 1er mai journée internationale
des travailleurs et des travailleuses
bonjour ita bonheur bonjour vous êtes à
présidente de l'union des femmes de la
martinique plusieurs associations dont
la vôtre appellent à une manifestation
particulière en marge des défilés
vous voulez rendre hommage à celle qui
s'investissent dans le mouvement social
oui nous avons pris cette initiative
effectivement à l'union des femmes de
martinique d'appeler à une mobilisation
unitaire de toutes les femmes qui
s'investissent dans le mouvement social
parce que demain
comme vous l'avez dit eh bien il s'agit
de la journée internationale des
travailleuses et des travailleurs il
s'agit pas de la fête du travail
il s'agit pas pour nous de fêter le
travail mais il s'agit justement de dire
et de répéter très fortement ce qui ne
va pas pour les femmes
aujourd'hui dans le monde du travail on
y reviendra très rapidement mais quand
vous dites celles qui s'investissent
dans le mouvement social ce sont les
salariés ce sont les militantes et bien
je vais dire que ce sont toutes les
femmes parce qu'on sait très bien que
les femmes sont très nombreuses à
s'investir dans la citoyenneté tout
simplement que ce soit dans des
associations que ce soit dans des
associations de quartier associations
sportives mais aussi des syndicats
les femmes sont très nombreuses même si
elles ne sont pas à des postes de
direction très souvent mais elles sont
là et doit de plaisance m
il ya de plus en plus bien sûr des chefs
d'entreprise l'ensemble une femme qui
est chef d'entreprise elle fait société
elf et social pourquoi pas si elle veut
se joindre à nous et être siaulai les
constats que nous faisons effectivement
parce qu'il peut y avoir dans une
entreprise des choses qui se font et des
choses positives pour les femmes
donc il y à dents dans tout ce champ
social
effectivement des femmes travailleuses
mais des femmes souvent en situation
précaire des femmes en situation de
chômage est en cdd des retraités aussi
parce qu'elles sont touchés par les
problèmes qui touchent fin qui qui qui
sont dans les femmes sont victimes c'est
tout au long de leur vie ce qui a deux
traduits avec brut à bonheur ce que vous
répondez bouquet sur votre voulait poste
parce que quand vous dites que c'est
l'occasion pour vous de dire ce qui ne
va pas reparler de situation précaire
des chômeuses et des partialité des cdi
et que dire des retraités on en parle
beaucoup en ce moment mais oui tout à
fait mais comme les femmes ont vécu
pendant toute leur vie professionnelle
des 10 des inégalités de salaires
notamment et de pas encore professionnel
est bien bien entendu cela se retrouve
jusqu'au bout de leur vie
c'est à dire qu'elles ont des retraites
qui sont environ 40% moins importante
que celle des hommes
il ya eu des interruptions également
dans le processus ce professionnel de
ces femmes parce qu'avec des
interruptions parce qu'elles ont été
payés moins cher parce qu'elles ont été
au chômage plus souvent parce qu'elles
ont eu des enfants auxquels on penser
que c'est un bon temps d'arrêter pour
s'occuper de leurs enfants parce
qu'elles sont dans des emplois précaires
parce qu'elles ont eu aussi des emplois
contrats aidés et tout cela bien entendu
ça pèse au moment où on part à la
retraite livrer treize au traitement
quantifier ce que vous décrivez
tout à fait il ya les chiffres de
l'insee donc on sait que en martinique
par exemple la différence de salaire
global entre femmes et hommes est moins
importante qu'en france mais c'est pas
parce qu'on est plus égalitaire c'est
tout simplement parce que les salaires
sont beaucoup plus tirée vers le bas en
martinique qu'en france donc les 27%
qu'on a en france
ici sont entre 10 et 11% par exemple
mais ça ne signifie pas que les femmes
swiss et l'égalité par le bas et ce
n'est pas ce que nous recherchons mais
vu le temps qu'on depuis le temps qu'on
en parlait ce qu'il y a quand même une
sorte de d'écrêtement est ce que les
choses s'améliorent doucement orange
dans la disparité des disparités de
salaires entre femmes et hommes
heureusement que les choses s'améliorent
parce que sinon ça serait à désespérer
c'est fini il faut quand même dire que
c'est c'est l'oeuvre aussi de la
pression citoyenne parce que s'il n'y
avait pas cette pression notamment des
féministes mais aussi des démocrates et
c est bien les choses n'avancerait pas
donc c'est pour cela qu'il faut
continuer ce que nous disons demain
c'est pour ça qu'il faut continuer à se
mobiliser et à rester présente et
visible dans cette manifestation
notamment alors situation pour les
femmes de martinique un peu compliqué
vous l'avez rappelé rita bonheur et le
tout dans un contexte général martinique
pas forcément favorable main bien sûr
c'est par exemple avec cette vagabondage
riz dans le secteur du transport la cft
une mosaïque sur le centre
quand même le poumon de l'économie de
l'île il y a eu des effets remarquer
remarquable pour l'activité économique
des femmes notamment
c'est pas pour rien que la présidente de
l'association des usagers
c'est une femme je pense qu'elle a été
très sensible à ce problème est
effectivement bon nous avons eu
l'occasion de dénoncer ce qui se passe
dans le transport les femmes sont les
plus grandes utilisatrices des
transports en commun les femmes
utilisent effectivement le les
transports en commun non seulement pour
aller au travail quand elles en ont un
mais aussi pour toutes les tâches qui
leur sont dévolues c'est à dire la
famille les enfants
le fait d'être aidantes familial c'est à
dire de s'occuper des parents âgés etc
et donc le fait qu'il n'y ait pas de
transport et bien cela impact non
seulement sur leur travail
bien sûr mais sur leur vie sociale tout
simplement sur leur sécurité
ce but beaucoup de femmes faire du stop
à 18h heure pour rentrer chez elle bien
sûr et comment savoir comment faire pour
rentrer chez soi quand on a fini de
travailler et qu'il n'y a pas de bus on
est exposé effectivement à toute
l'insécurité qui lie à sur les routes
aujourd'hui
autre secteur sur lequel vous tirer la
sonnette d'alarmé rita bonheur celui de
la santé oui on sait que quand on n'a
pas de revenus suffisants et bien on
néglige sa santé on sait aussi que quand
on a des problèmes comme notamment les
femmes victimes de violences eh bien on
ne s'occupe pas de sa santé parce qu on
est en mode de survie donc tout c'est
tout tout ce qui arrive dans la vie des
femmes a un impact sur leur santé et
bien entendu avec la situation qu'il ya
aujourd'hui dans la santé en général
eh bien les femmes en pâtissent bien
entendu tout le monde en pâtit
mais nous avons envie de dire que avec
des revenus moindres
eh bien on regarde on réfléchit à deux
fois avant d'aller se faire soigner les
dents avant d'aller se faire soigner les
yeux par exemple on va penser à ces
enfants d'abord avant de penser à soi
et puis il y a tout le scandale du
chlordécone bien sûr alors c'est vrai
qu'on parle beaucoup de cancers de la
prostate c'est vrai que l'on dit on se
pose des questions mais on sait très
bien que de toute façon les femmes sont
souvent plus vulnérables au niveau de
leur santé quand il y a tous ces
problèmes de la banane d'auteur
effectivement il y à tous ce problème
des femmes qui sont dans le secteur de
la banane
et qui sont surexposés aussi au
chlordécone méritas bonheur j'ai envie
de vous dire qu'il ya eu quand même des
annonces présidentielles la semaine
dernière pour améliorer le quotidien de
la population
vous n'avez pas été rassurés par les
propos d' emmanuel macron le président
la république notamment sur les
retraites
non nous sommes vraiment dans
l'expectative parce que d'abord il y à
beaucoup d'annoncés sur des mesures qui
existent déjà
quand par exemple on nous parle de la
caf de saisir la caf pour les problèmes
de pension alimentaire est bien la caf
dit mais c'est une chose que nous
faisons déjà depuis plus d'un an
elie à d'autres mesures comme celles là
qui en fait se dégonfle up comme des
ballons parce que elle existe déjà mais
aussi sur le flanc de la pente plus
l'île de batz écoutez nous ne sommes pas
les seuls à le dire donc il faut le dire
très fortement d'ailleurs demain aussi
dans les rues de fort de france il
faudra le dire et nous nous allons le
dire avec ce zoom et cet oeil
particulier des conséquences pour les
femmes de ces mesures pour lesquelles
nous ne croyons pas et notamment ce qui
concerne quand il s'agit de travailler
plus mais comment peut-on travailler
plus quand on est dans des conditions
difficiles
et qu'est ce qu'on nous offre en fait
pour travailler plus et est ce qu'on a
besoin j'ai envie de dire de travailler
sur de nouveaux justifier d'une retraite
aujourd'hui quand une femme a passé
beaucoup de temps dans des emplois
précaires dans des emplois aider à
s'occuper de ses enfants et qu'elle est
usée par toute cette vie et bien on ne
peut pas lui demander de travailler
encore plus pour pouvoir avoir une
retraite digne
nous disons non il ya aussi le phénomène
mitu qui a permis aux saints victime de
harcèlement de sexisme de faire entendre
leur voix c'est parti tout azimut et
aujourd'hui il y a nécessité d'organiser
ce phénomène qui prend de l'ampleur
les associations comme la vôtre l'union
des femmes pourrait devrait par exemple
avec la justice des organisations
syndicales
alors la justice nous oeuvrons déjà
puisqu'elle nous sommes partenaires de
ça va mieux
oui mais c'est quand même un partenaire
avec qui nous travaillons bon quand il
ya des choses qui ne vont pas on le dit
mais quand les choses avancent il faut
le dire aussi
il y à l'observatoire qui s'est mis en
place peu sur les violences envers les
femmes donc il commence un travail aussi
de cohésion
mais en ce qui nous concerne nous avons
effectivement pris le problème à bras le
camp et c'est un de nos unes de nos
lignes directrices on va dire que nous
continuions que nous amplifions pour nos
75 ans puisqu'il faut quand même qu'on
rappelle que nous sommes dans la
négociation voilà très toujours très
active et dynamique et donc nous avons
effectivement commencé un travail de
fond avec certains syndicats nous
l'aurons pour ce travail de fond
exactement alors nous leur avons proposé
un partenariat un échange de pratiques
on va dire sur le thème de la prévention
et le traitement des femmes victimes de
violences sexistes et sexuelles au
travail
donc nous avons rencontré un écho
favorable en tout cas au niveau de deux
voire trois syndicats puisqu'il y en a
un qui a commencé à s'intéresser à la
chose à la chose et ce travail de fond
il consiste à être vraiment partenaires
sur cette question c'est à dire comment
lui fm peut apporter sa compétence son
expertise quand même un peu en la
matière aux syndicats qui travaillent
déjà bien sûr mais pour pouvoir faire
quelque chose de plus approfondie il y
aura notamment exemple d'afficher plus
approfondie alors je rentre dans les
détails il y aura notamment une campagne
d'affichage dans les entreprises ou les
syndicats avec qui nous travaillons sont
présents un affichage commun d'abord
pour rappeler aux à l'employeur ses
obligations ensuite pour di rosa aux
salariés que les syndicats sont présents
sur ce champ là aussi et qu'ils peuvent
agir avec nous et ensuite pour informer
les victimes des lieux possibles pour
pouvoir être accompagnés et notamment
donc les lieux que lui fm
a donc notre espace des côtes mais aussi
nos deux permanences que nous faisons à
trinité et à ducos et puis ça va se
poursuivre parce que il y a aussi besoin
de formation et de sensibilisation des
salariés notamment des responsables
syndicaux parce que c'est aussi une
façon de voir comment faire un premier
accueil de ces personnes victimes et
comment mieux les orienter aussi au delà
de ce premier mérite à bonheur la cause
féministe les causes féministes trouve
de plus en plus d'échos favorables
notamment auprès de ceux qui peuvent
vous aider vous avez parlé de la justice
les politiques également une évolution
de 2 de la proche des politiques
vis-à-vis de la cause féministe je
dirais que les politiques ne peuvent pas
ne pas s'en empare et puisqu'on en parle
énormément et que c'est un peu dans
l'air du temps
heureusement mais entre la parole et les
actes est réelle il y a quand même une
marge qu'il nous faut franchir c'est à
dire oui quand on est sensible à la
cause des femmes etc
mais comment ça se concrétise réellement
c'est à dire quelle politique se met en
place et c'est pour cela que nous
interpellons régulièrement les
politiques sur ces points mais je
voudrais rappeler que sur ce 1er mai
c'est tous ensemble que nous allons agir
merci l'union des femmes de la
martinique qui donnera des voix que
d'autres associations demain matin pour
à destination des correctifs humains sms
de vie aussi qui est une jeune
association qui viennent se crée sur les
femmes qui s'investissent dans le social
merci rita bonheur bonne journée à vous